- [Voiceover] Where do you
think babies come from?
- Uh...
(electronic music)
- They sell them at hospitals sometimes.
- Oh, they sell them at hospitals?
- Mm hmm.
They're in like cages.
You need the doctor to get the key,
unlock 'em and get the kid that you want.
- How much do they cost?
- Ten dollars!
(laughs)
- When I was a baby,
I was really big
so they had to cut my mom's stomach
and they had to stitch it up.
- They come from up in heaven.
And that's all I know.
- Is there another way?
- Yeah.
- Just use the nice words.
(boy mutters)
in their private spot.
- Usually after marriage,
the two couples kiss
and then man gives the woman something
to help the baby hatch.
- They grow sperms and then.
(laughs)
- And then the woman becomes pregnant
and really
fat.
- Come on, lets do it.
Okay, lets go to my house.
Uh oh, I have a baby in my tummy,
lets go to the hospital.
Gotta have my baby.
Yeah, lets go home.
Now she's five.
Ooh lets go to the park.
Yay.
- I'm just curious of what that was.
I didn't know what that,
this whole situation...
- That was kissing.
- Oh, okay.
So I kiss mommy.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Whew.